so it started again a certain stripe of
online commentator has started going on
about the Doctor Who viewing numbers
about how they're bad the radios are bad
cuz it's woke they don't always say that
in the same sentence but it's usually
the same kind of people uh # rip Doctor
Who and all the like here's the thing um
everybody needs to understand the
ratings will never be what they were
when Doctor Who was at its peak Best
ratings show ever got was Voyage of the
damn 2007 13 million people the show
will never no matter what it does no
matter how popular it is will never hit
that number again because that was a
completely different media landscape
2007 Netflix had only just started
streaming the number of things that you
could be doing with your time has vastly
increased the number of people who go
I'll just watch it later their ability
to do that is vastly increased so anyone
citing the overnight numbers those don't
even take bbci player into account the
Consolidated numbers do but that doesn't
take into account simal cast on Disney
plus the ratings have never been a very
good metric but at this point they are
virtually useless as an actual measure
of popularity